khabib nurmagomedov is threatening
equate the UFC you know i've waited like
a month to do this because after the
last video i made don't really want to
talk about his fans don't like me very
much if you clicked on this video and
you love khabib just come here just get
try and get off on the better foot and
last that last time your boy you're
beating the [__] or mine you know we
we got off on the wrong foot just fight
up and now you weren't in it i wasn't in
it
we're just fight funds can we not just
that's friends yeah I got absolutely
hammered on me last could be related
video obviously just beating McGregor I
was a bit disappointed 15,000 dislikes I
cameraman just dropped his jaw of the
floor sixty-two thousand likes though so
not all bad fight fans are not like any
other internet community so like YouTube
drama do a video on that yeah you'll get
a few dislikes people say the odd
comment there's not that aggression that
you talk about music football like even
football fans hate each other but
nothing like five fans I found the drama
queens I didn't want to get off on the
wrong but like the [__] hatred that
they hate you all right I was wrong on
what I said in the last video I didn't
say the whole footage that McGregor was
involved as well at the end and I I made
the fight right after I'd had a hangover
I'd walk up and watch Conor McGregor get
beat by it wasn't the best time but can
we just start from clean slate let's
starting from now so autumn Loeb of the
vs. took a gov basically Conor's
training partner and curbs training
partner we're gonna fight each other he
was training apart and I was the one who
jumped in the cage and started scrapping
with McGregor and now Dana's suggesting
that he's gonna be fired the fights
canceled khabib he's not too happy about
that so could be basically said on
Instagram why did you fire anyone when
their team attack the boss and injured
people no one said anything about
insulting my homeland religion nation
family then you think to punish my team
when both teams fought if you see I
started it I do not agree I finished
what he had started and if you don't
believe that corner threw the first
punch check the video thief
he hit my brother first khabib then says
if you decide to fire him then you're
gonna lose me too we never give up on
our brothers in Russia and I will go to
the end for my brother and what
more thing you can keep my money that
you're withholding you're pretty busy
with that slightly a night heli I hope
it won't get stuck in your throat
I must admit right well someone who I
kind of thought was a bit boring before
the Connor fight the last thing I think
you peep is now is boring I admire the
[__] gangster of the kid and the
anger of him I don't agree with all of
his actions but this I kind of admire
because he's throwing his weight around
in the right way and he's trying to
protect his teammate is he right and
everything you saying probably not but
you've gotta kind of respect someone
who's willing to quit when they do
millions of pounds from potential UFC
fights just to protect his brother no
like I said before when I first analyzed
this fight and the post fight chaos that
happened all the footage wasn't out and
that's my fault for not waiting for it
maybe I was harsh on Kirby but I
definitely was pretty harsh on it don't
get us wrong I stand by the fact that
could be did start it everyone keeps
saying Connor threw the first punch nor
could be jumped [__] feet-first into
one who's Connors training partners
before corner threw a punch at any other
history in importance I think Connor
knew at the time it was all kicking off
and Connor also lost control that means
that some blame should go to Connor for
making it worse but make no mistake
could be [__] star this and I
wouldn't agree with anyone who says any
different if you are gonna suggest the
khabib jump in feet first into a crowd
and gone and fighting his [__] head
off which I came to respect once again
because the man is a crazy [__] hard
bastard he started this he was the first
one to jump in and go [__] crazy
Connor made things worse well none of a
sentient also deserves a bit of blame
and let's be honest Corner [__] won't
keep evil for long enough to flip and
create a lot of this I'm glad Connor
didn't press charges that would have
made things even more so and I just
don't think it's in the man's character
but when you look back at all of this
it's like a domino effect from autumn
low above doing an interview about
khabib to be wouldn't just let the words
go had to go up and get in his face and
slap him or whatever he did it was hard
to look like he slapped them then
McGregor responds then could be response
after the fight and it's like one thing
after another thing after nothing in it
he does just feel like khabib could just
let words go a little bit better than
what
does because don't get me wrong I
respect his gangster and all of that and
the fact that he's a hard man and you
know you have to back up what you say
about could be but equally you're a UFC
champion now they are going to be people
talking [__] about khabib nurmagomedov
every [__] day you can't just go and
hit everyone who says everything about
you now I hope that khabib gets a
lenient punishment and that Connor gets
a lenient punishment and people
understand that this has gotten out of
hand and that they can call it a truce
and just say look from now on we keep it
in the cage none of this [__] ever
happens again we were both out of order
we were both in the wrong and I do kind
of feel like people will be happy
because Connor kind of has gotten what
he deserved from in a lot of people's
opinions that all of the trash talk and
has finally come back to haunt him
because kabhi was so mentally strong he
didn't let him get in his head and he
dished out in the cage which begs the
question why did khabib want to run and
fight Dylan Danis I still don't get that
that is the one thing I'm still yeah
Dylan Danis is Tom and [__] but you are
the world champion you proved your
[__] point mate what what more is
there to say I think possibly there are
two things the way could be beat
McGregor
it wasn't an extremely violent ending
where he rearranged his face like he
wanted to could be for a smart fight he
out skilled Connery
he took him down he wore him down in
yeah he beat him up on the feet a bit
but it wasn't an absolute destruction
that he really craved and first of all
and then when you combine that with the
mental torment that he'd went through it
just didn't satisfy him he needed more
and what a bad man he must be because
you've just beaten Conor McGregor and
you still aren't satisfied with it Conn
actually early got into his head a lot
but just not enough for it to have a
negative effect but could be restraining
himself towards Conor at the end and
just let that go then he just goes crazy
I still don't understand it I think
adrenaline played a part actually I do
think that the win I've proved me poin I
can take on the [__]
and all of the Sydney's over the cage
you know fighters are gonna just fight
sometimes and that's that's that and I
think I was harsh on could be that you
know these are not basketball players
they're not [__] footballers these
guys punch people for a living in some
aims like when you send a [__] you
know zookeeper in a cage with a lion
sometimes the inevitable happens that
being said it doesn't excuse it we've
had mayhem Miller and the Diaz fight
after the fight we had Paul daily but
we've never had anything this bad and I
just think that he can't happen again
basically slap them on the wrists let
them do a rematch or whatever the [__]
but make sure it doesn't happen again
and I think khabib has got the UFC by
the balls by the way because the in need
khabib now to make the corner fight and
they know that that's the money fight
that happened now this is a huge fight
and could be will walk I I fully believe
that guys like this guy's a man of his
[__] word Dana has got a real
decision to make now because in the past
the only person who's ever challenged
the USA in one it's called McGregor
because he knew he had them by the balls
financially khabib has not just got them
by the balls for the money fight but I
just think we know the guys [__]
serious if there's one thing we've
learned from this is khabib is a serious
man interestingly kabooms dad who could
be clearly listens to a lot as come on
said he forgives Conor for everything
that was said although looking at him I
don't know why I just I'm not sure I
believe him maybe the word he had with
Vladimir Putin has helped smooth things
over all you didn't say that
well hello of khabib thanks for coming
and thanks for bringing your daddy have
a seat I got these chairs from MFI
lovely
[Music]
well done anyway seen the fight big win
Congrats
well don't your father as well obviously
he taught you everything you know by
beating the hell out years an
eight-year-old it wasn't easy I'd tell
you some names you would start winning
and enough to get the Bears under one
bloody hell
so who does could be fight next Ferguson
deserves it the guy's an absolute animal
his performance against Pettis was
[__] fantastic that is a fight I blew
love to finally [__] see
Diaz once it shock there anything
straighten at the title fight even
though you haven't fought in [__]
three years or whatever the hell it is
me I like the way there's fights but
make no mistake the man is one of the
dumbest fight as I've ever seen in the
USA like I'm sure Alfred a sport like
you know you're too dumb for this sport
because when he beat McGregor and even
after the fight against McGregor he
could have cut the Paulton his name to
another level and he's just wasted that
by sitting on his [__] ass and now he
thinks he can just walk straight into a
fight but on a real McGregor kind of did
that but like he went and did other
things he's fought Alvarez since then
double champion fought me whether his
name is grown he has done fuck-all me
what do you think you deserve a title
fight for you [__] idiot anyway
enough of that
I just I'm annoyed cuz I actually like
watching this guy fight but he's just
any excuse to pull out and he's [__]
God know that he's had a taste of the
big money anyway he's a different guy
it's gonna be McGregor why is that the
USA want to make the [__] money
fights we all know that and the real
question is will it be any different the
second time around and the answer is yes
now before you start calling me a Conor
dick right now in the comments that's
because nor two fights are ever the same
although some are very [__] similar
so is it gonna be different enough to
give McGregor a real chance see a lot of
people took the opportunity after the
Kabir fight to be like Nuri was [__]
always thought he was crap you say
overrated and it's like the guys are
quality UFC fight I like gon take that
away from he has beaten some of the best
fighters in that company like let's cut
the [__] yeah did he perform there was
best of his ability on the night
[__] no that was not the best Conor
McGregor we have seen by a long shot if
this game plan his attacks were mediocre
in that fight that was an average
version of McGregor the probably the
worst McGregor I've ever [__] seen
even the Diaz one fight was much more
dynamic and angles and you know the
accuracy was off in that fight but there
was a lot more I don't get me wrong he
probably showed more heart in the khabib
fight than he did they put aside from
that like I don't I didn't think he came
at it and he went near his normal level
and if you disagree with that you know
you can leave any comment you want
because as far as I'm concerned I'm well
within my rights to say that this was
not the 100% McGregor McGregor fought
like a rich man yeah he fought like a
mom of two years off he fought like a
man who didn't really care that much
which was weird because you can tell he
really does but when he's walking
towards khabib square on flat-footed
there's no bouncing in and out and being
hard to hit and you know luring into the
curve even of the trap that he did to
Aldo and the dynamic unorthodox movement
and the angles and the precision none of
that was there
jinan I mean so we know for a fact Conor
McGregor can fight better than he did
and I actually watched a video from
Chael Sonnen and I think Jill sometimes
gets his conclusions wrong but the brain
of the man when it comes to MMA is
fantastic in my opinion and he said like
McGregor did so many of the basics right
in the wrestling department to give
himself enough time and space to attack
the thing was with McGregor when the
attacks came his attacks were not as
good as what they normally are and maybe
if he can do that next time we will at
least have a far more competitive fight
with not a whole two years off and you
know you look back at some UFC fights in
the past Randy Couture look Chuck
Liddell that went one way or then went
another way you know
Rockhold vs. Bisping actually is a
really good example of when Rockhold
cleaned
Bisping just decisively found it quite
easy a bit like this fight actually
and then Bisping comes back with a
better game plan looked much better even
on short notice and wins decisively it
can't happen
McGregor is seriously going to have to
get his [__] together though because I
watched John Cavanaugh's interview on
Joe Rogan as always class podcast boss
John Kavanagh is probably keeping his
cool and not giving the way too much but
he must look at that fight and see
disappointing version of a fighter that
he created and he helped build and a man
who looks miles away from his best and
that that should worry the [__] out of
him and McGregor because they it impacts
their whole image their whole gym that
everything that they've built up
honestly I think Connor at his best can
be anyone in that division on on his day
so let's say what happened say if they
actually make the fight you can let us
know in the comments below what you lot
think you do tennis talk a lot in the
comments I'm actually really excited
about MMA moving forward you've got the
John Jones fight you've got Daniel
Cormier fighting in boxing we've got
Tyson Fury Deontay Wilder I'm gonna be
covering all of that and all the usual
stuff I give so if you enjoyed this
video hit the like button subscribe
thanks for watching and I'll see you
later